So let's see if we can do some DRam
access scheduling to take advantage
of the fast page access
that we can have.
let's assume we have a DRam
memory that has 32,
one bit arrays,
just like the one we have seen before.
Each array is one megabyte.
And it's organized as
two to the tenth rows,
times two to the tenth bits per row.
Each array is a 16 megabit array,
organized as two to the 12th rows,
which is 4,096 rows,
times two to the 12th bits per row.
And the 24 bit address,
that we feed to this memory where bits
are numbered zero to 23 is
thus divided by the into
a 12 bit row address which is
the upper bits of the address and
the address which is the lower
to bits of the address.
Of course the processor,
when it issues this 24 bit
physical address wants to access
a 32 bit memory location.
Each ship is fed this address, and
the 32 chips together
represent a 32 bit memory.
So one chip, for example,
might hold bit number 7,
from all the words in
the 16 megaword memory.
Let's say we have Cache Misses currently
pending for the following addresses.
Let's assume that it takes ten
nanoseconds to open a page,
that it takes two nanoseconds to read
something from the row buffer once
the page is open, and
five nanoseconds to close a page.
These operations, how long do they take,
if we do them in this particular order,
and how long do they take if we
are allowed to reorder them so
that the time gets reduced?